as I'm driving over here I was thinking
okay you all know fast is coming out you
know I make this movie with my heart
and I'm thinking what do I need to know
and my daughter who's 15 wants to sing
I'm thinking this is the perfect
opportunity
for me to ask Kelly
what it's like
to have a magic ability like her voice
and what advice
could I give my 15 year old daughter who
has a dream of singing yeah dude that's
it I mean I think that Jesse and I would
probably say the same thing you just
keep hustling we just kept I think
people only know me from American Idol
but you don't know what I did before
there's a muscle in there
like people will say oh unless
the show you of Grammys of all these
things I'm like do you know how many
people said no to me you're to this
you're to that you're not this you need
to be this it's like left and right and
like really there is no there's no
there's no other advice other than
anything in life like just do you and
you know what I'm saying and people will
follow like even you said like you've
been a part of this franchise for so
this is the tenth one right tenth one
that's because you love it it's a parent
it's organic you have the chemistry of
all the characters the fact that you
have such longevity with all the cast
members and they keep coming back
keep loving to be a part of it like
that's that's rare like a lot of people
don't do that so it's like sometimes
magic happens but I think the thing that
I always tell people on The Voice too
like artists is like quit trying to be
another artist be whoever you are
because we already have that artist so
like do what do you do and even if it
doesn't like you know people have always
said like oh well if you if you don't
pick or you don't fit in this box it's
not going to work out I'm like I
literally love every genre of music I
work wherever I want do whatever I want
whenever and I think that's the key is
it's doing what you love because you
only get one life and I think we're
reminded of that the older we get you're
gonna have to get her on here oh she
would love to yeah all right all right
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]